thank you for joining us America we're
so glad you're with us this is your show
it's a show about your life yeah it
revolves around money but money touches
almost every area of your life it's not
like money is important you know people
that think money is not important or
people that generally don't have any
they have they act like that being poor
is somehow a virtue not a virtue virtue
at all it doesn't mean you're a bad
person it doesn't make you good because
you're poor come on it doesn't make you
a bad person if you're rich does it make
you a good person if you're rich you
know I have met crooked horrible nasty
rich people I've met crooked horrible
nasty poor people
turns out I'm gonna do with the money
it's got to it being crooked nasty jerk
you can be rich jerk or poor jerk or
still just jerk it's a decision to be a
jerk but somehow some of these political
ideologies out there floating around
somehow attached money to the issue it's
not going to do with the money and I
really like what Becca said in that last
segment when she was doing her debt free
scream she said I needed some money so I
prayed and God sent me the opportunity
to do some babysitting the opportunity
to do this an opportunity to do that
my friend rabbi Daniel lapin who wrote
the book is Orthodox Jewish rabbi wrote
the book thou shall prosper so one of my
favorite books of all time definitely in
my top 10 faves right wrote the foreword
to it I don't write the foreword to
books I write a lot of blurbs a lot of
my friends write books and I write a lot
of blurbs recommending the book if I
like the book and you know you know I
don't put it on every single person I
turn a lot of people down but but you
know the friends of mine that are
quality writers that have quality
thoughts to say I definitely put them a
Dave Ramsey thing on there right Dave
Remagen says read this book kind of
thing but I don't do forwards hardly
every but I did the forward to this one
you know the bow shall prosper by rabbi
Daniel lapin you need to read it by the
way but let's make you a wall because
it's it's
there's a lot going on in that book but
one of the things he says is the one
reasons that Jewish people have a
tendency to prosper is they don't look
for a job when they need money they look
for an opportunity to help someone an
opportunity to serve I think it's the
same thing but it's a different spirit a
different mentality what if you went
into a job interview a hundred percent
of the time you were there trying to
figure out how you could help that
company and instead of trying to get
hired by that company instead of getting
that company to give you money if you
just went and said how could I in your
mind in your spirit you said how could I
add value here how can I help these
people do better than they're doing how
can I be present here and everyone here
be glad that I'm here how can I serve
how can I lift what can I do that moves
things isn't that interesting if you
need money you need to look for an
opportunity to serve when someone serves
you at a restaurant unless you're just a
total but you leave them a you leave
them a thank you card don't you
with a green president's face on it it's
called a tip when we have a server
that's what we call in my restaurants we
have a server that does I'll be your
server tonight
when they serve us and we leave on the
tip do you feel bad if you get if you
have a waiter or waitress it does a
phenomenal job
now I'm not I'm not talking to those of
you that are jerks but the regular
people like you and me if somebody does
a great job you don't feel badly towards
the server when you leave them a tip do
you it's kind of like tipping your hat
in the old days it's kind of you're not
and then you're tipping and you it's
kind of like saying you did a good job
and you're I'm what when someone parked
my car in the rain called a valet and
they run out there with an umbrella and
make sure my wife doesn't get wet and
they open the door for her and put her
in do I feel badly giving that guy he's
out there in the cold and the rain
running around and I don't have to be
and my wife's not wet and life is good
on my planet happy wife happy life right
I mean yeah I feel badly when I get my
guy tip no he served well business is
the same way getting a jobs the same way
if you need more money you need more
opportunity to help someone that's what
you ought to pray for hey God give me
some give me some more opportunity to
help someone because almost all money
that comes your way in turn in terms of
pay is because you are providing some
level of service and the more service
you provide the more money you'll get
and the more people you provide service
to the more money you'll get the first
book I published is called financial
peace two words that don't go together
like airline service right
self-published little book sold another
trunk of my car I would go speak at some
Kiwanis Club with a bad suit and
overhead projector and I'd sell five
books at the back of the table and we
were selling them for $12 a piece so I
made $60 minus cost of goods sold so
make 3040 bucks
speaking that day and I helped five or
six people interesting that the
information in that book you know it
later became a big book and ended up
selling I guess we've sold about 3
million of those books now which means
we've helped 3 million people now nobody
was mad when I made $10 a book and I
helped 10 people but when I helped 10
million people and I made $10 a book now
I'm evil no I'm not that's just some of
you that have toxic screwed up theology
and ideology on how life works all it
means is I help that many more people or
I gave them the opportunity to be helped
immune from
the book helps by the way I read a John
Grisham book I read the new John Grisham
book through them
I read fiction on airplanes that makes
airplanes right flat faster and I think
I've read every John Grisham book among
many other authors that I've read every
book that wrote I every Brad door book
every Frank Peretti book I've read a lot
I read a lot of those guys and different
different genre of fiction so you know
it's just pure entertainment right it's
just a crime novel or whatever it is
right a CIA shoot-'em-up novel or
whatever it is right so so what how did
how did that author of writer of fiction
serve me he didn't change my life No
entertain me so I got pay money to go to
a movie I got pay money for cable TV
it's entertainment right pay money to go
to a play it's entertainment I'm paying
for the entertainment they served me I'm
not mad about the those guys and John
Grisham saw a whole lot more books and
Dave Ramsey I'll just tell you that
those of us that sell non-fiction books
we just wish we had a percentage of
sales or the fiction sales fiction sales
go bananas it's awesome but they're
serving more people than I'm serving so
you make more money than I'm making all
the book sales so if you want more money
maybe instead of praying for a job maybe
you pray for the opportunity to serve
someone you look for a way to serve
someone how can I be of service
and as my friend rabbi says when you
serve someone then they give you
certificates of appreciation for your
service with presidents faces on little
green certificates and that's how you
say thank you in a capitalistic economy
you leave a tip you allow a company and
make a profit that served you a lot of
you own Apple products Apple iPhones and
iPads and Mac books and some of you own
Dell they have served you that piece of
equipment makes your life better or at
least in your mind it does probably
actually does make your life better
and so Bill Gates has served a lot of
people made a lot of money doing it
Apple has served a lot of people they've
made a lot of money doing it so maybe
you need to serve more and you need to
help more people make their life better
whether it's with entertainment the
quality of the entertainment the scale
of the entertainment but maybe it's with
something that changes their life maybe
you're simply feeding them how can you
serve more that's the question you ask
that's where money comes from darling
that's where your income comes hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]